The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, we're going
to talk a bit more about
parallelism and about how you
get performance out of
parallel codes.
And also, we're going to take
a little bit of a tour
underneath the Cilk++ runtime
system so you can get an idea
of what's going on underneath
and why it is that when you
code stuff, how it is that it
gets mapped, scheduled on the
processors.
So when people talk about
parallelism, one of the first
things that often comes up is
what's called Amdahl's Law.
Gene Amdahl was the architect
of the IBM360 computers who
then left IBM and formed his
own company that made
competing machines and he made
the following observation
about parallel computing,
he said--
and I'm paraphrasing here--
half your application is
parallel and half is serial.
You can't get more than a factor
of two speed up, no
matter how many processors
it runs on.
So if you think about it, if
it's half parallel and you
managed to make that parallel
part run in zero time, still
the serial part will be half of
the time and you only get a
factor of two speedup.
You can generalize that to say
if some fraction alpha can be
run in parallel and the rest
must be run serially, the
speedup is at most 1
over 1 minus alpha.
OK, so this was used in the
1980s in particular to say why
it was that parallel computing
had no future, because you
simply weren't going to be able
to get very much speedups
from parallel computing.
You're going to spend extra
hardware on the parallel parts
of the system and yet you might
be limited in terms of
how much parallelism there is
in a particular application
and you wouldn't get
very much speedup.
You wouldn't get the bang for
the buck, if you will.
So things have changed today
that make that not quite the
same story.
The first thing is that with
multicore computers, it is
pretty much just as inexpensive
to produce a p
processor right now, like six
processor machine as it is a
one processor machine.
so it's not like you're actually
paying for those
extra processing cores.
They come for free.
Because what else are you're
going to use that silicon for?
And the other thing is that
we've had a large growth of
understanding of problems
for which there's ample
parallelism, where that
amount of time is,
in fact, quite small.
And the main place these things
come from, it turns
out, this analysis is kind of a
throughput kind of analysis.
OK, it says, gee, I only get
50% speedup for that
application, but what most
people care about in most
interactive applications, at
least for a client side
programming, is response time.
And for any problem that you
have that has a response time
that's too long and its compute
intensive, using
parallelism to make it so that
the response is much zippier
is definitely worthwhile.
And so this is true, even for
things like game programs.
So in game programs, they don't
have quite a response
time problem, they have what's
called a time box problem,
where you have a certain
amount of time--
13 milliseconds typically--
because you need some slop to
make sure that you can go from
one frame to another, but about
13 milliseconds to do a
rendering of whatever the frame
is that the game player
is going to see on his computer
or her computer.
And so in that time, you want to
do as much as you possibly
can, and so there's a big
opportunity there to take
advantage of parallelism in
order to do more, have more
quality graphics, have better
AI, have better physics and
all the other components that
make up a game engine.
But one of the issues
with Amdahl's Law--
and this analysis is a cogent
analysis that Amdahl made--
but one of the issues here is
that it doesn't really say
anything about how fast
you can expect your
application to run.
In other words, this is a nice
sort of thing, but who really
can decompose their application
into the serial
part and the part that
can be parallel?
Well fortunately, there's been a
lot of work in the theory of
parallel systems to answer this
question, and we're going
to go over some of that really
outstanding research that
helps us understand what
parallelism is.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about what
parallelism is and come up with
a very specific measure
of parallelism, quantify
parallelism, OK?
We're also going to talk a
little bit about scheduling
theory and how the Cilk++
runtime system works.
And then we're going to have
a little chess lesson.
So who here plays chess?
Nobody plays chess anymore.
Who plays Angry Birds?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So you don't have to know
anything about chess to learn
this chess lesson, that's OK.
So we'll start out with
what is parallelism?
So let's recall first the
basics of Cilk++.
So here's the example of the
lousy Fibonacci that everybody
parallelizes because it's
good didactically.
We have the Cilk spawn statement
that says that the
child can execute in parallel
with the parent caller and the
sync that says don't go past
this point until all your
spawn children have returned.
And that's a local sync,
that's just a
sync for that function.
It's not a sync across
the whole machine.
So some of you may have had
experience with open MP
barriers, for example,
that's a sync
across the whole machine.
This is not, this is just a
local sync for this function
saying when I sync, make sure
all my children have returned
before going past this point.
And just remember also that Cilk
keywords grant permission
for parallel execution.
They don't command parallel
execution.
OK so we can always execute
our code serially
if we choose to.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Can't this runtime figure that
spawning an extra child would
be more expensive?
Can't it like look at
this and be like--
PROFESSOR: We'll go into it.
I'll show you how it works
later in the lecture.
I'll show you how it works and
then we can talk about what
knobs you have to tune, OK?
So it's helpful to have
an execution model for
something like this.
And so we're going to look at
an abstract execution model,
which is basically asking what
does the instruction trace
look like for this program?
So normally when you execute a
program, you can imagine one
instruction executing
after the other.
And if it's a serial program,
all those instructions
essentially form a long chain.
Well there's a similar thing for
parallel computers, which
is that instead of a chain as
you'll see, it gets bushier
and it's going to be a directed
acyclic graph.
So let's take a look
at how we do this.
So we'll the example
of fib of four.
So what we're going to do
is start out here with a
rectangle here that I want you
think about as sort of a
function call activation
record.
So it's a record on a stack.
It's got variables associated
with it.
The only variable I'm going to
keep track of is n, so that's
what the four is there.
OK, so we're going to
do fib of four.
So we've got in this activation
frame, we have the
variable four and now what I've
done is I've color coded
the fib function here and into
the parts that are all serial.
So there's a serial part up to
where it spawns, then there's
recursively calling the fib and
then there's returning.
So there's sort of three parts
to this function, each of
which is, in fact, a chain
of serial instruction.
I'm going to collapse those
chains into a single circle
here that I'm going
to call a strand.
OK, now what we do is we execute
the strand, which
corresponds to executing the
instructions and advancing the
program calendar up until
the point we hit this
fib of n minus 1.
At that point, I basically
call fib of n minus 1.
So in this case, it's now
going to be fib of 3.
So that means I create a child
and start executing in the
child, this prefix part
of the function.
However, unlike I were doing an
ordinary function call, I
would make this call and then
this guy would just sit here
and wait until this
frame was done.
But since it's a spawn, what
happens is I'm actually going
to continue executing in the
parent and execute, in fact,
the green part.
So in this case, evaluating
the arguments, etc.
Then it's going to spawn here,
but this guy, in fact, is
going to what it does when it
gets here is it evaluates n
minus 2, it does a call
of fib of n minus 2.
So I've indicated that this was
a called frame by showing
it in a light color.
So these are spawn, spawn,
call, meanwhile
this thing is going.
So at this point, we now have
one, two, three things that
are operating in parallel
at the same time.
We keep going on, OK?
So this guy that does a spawn
and has a continuation, this
one does a call, but while
he's doing a call, he's
waiting for the return
so he doesn't start
executing the successor.
He stalled at the
Cilk sink here.
And we keep executing and so
as you can see, what's
happening is we're actually
creating a directed acyclic
graph of these strands.
So here basically, this guy was
able to execute because
both of the children, one that
he had spawned and one that he
had called, have returned.
And so this fella, therefore,
is able then
to execute the return.
OK, so the addition of x plus y
in particular, and then the
return to the parent.
And so what we end up with is of
all these serial chains of
instructions that are
represented by these strands,
all these circles, they're
embedded in the call tree like
you would have in an ordinary
serial execution.
You have a call tree that you
execute up and down, you walk
it like a stack normally.
Now, in fact, what we have is
embedded in there is the
parallel execution which form a
DAG, directed acyclic graph.
So when you start thinking in
parallel, you have to start
thinking about the DAG as your
execution model, not a chain
of instructions.
And the nice thing about this
particular execution model
we're going to be looking at is
nowhere did I say how many
processors we were running on.
This is a processor
oblivious model.
It doesn't know how many
processors you're running on.
We simply in the execution
model, are thinking about
abstractly what can run in
parallel, not what actually
does run in parallel
in an execution.
So any questions about
this execution model?
OK.
So just so that we have some
terminology, so the parallel
instruction stream is a DAG
with vertices and edges.
Each vertex is a strand, OK?
Which is a sequence of
instructions not containing a
call spawn sync, a return or
thrown exception, if you're
doing exceptions.
We're not going to really talk
about exceptions much.
So they are supported in the
software that we'll be using,
but for most part, we're
not going to have
to worry about them.
OK so there's an initial strand
where you start, and a
final strand where you end.
Then each edge is a spawn or
a call or return or what's
called a continue edge or a
continuation edge, which goes
from the parent, when a parent
spawns something to the next
instruction after the spawn.
So we can classify the edges
in that fashion.
And I've only explain this for
spawm and sync, as you recall
from last time, we also talked
about Cilk four.
It turns out Cilk four is
converted to spawns and syncs
using a recursive divide
and conquer approach.
We'll talk about that next
time on Thursday.
So we'll talk more about Cilk
four and how it's implemented
and the implications of how
loop parallelism works.
So at the fundamental level,
the runtime system is only
concerned about spawns
and syncs.
Now given that we have a DAG,
so I've taken away the call
tree and just left the strands
of a computation.
It's actually not the same as
the computation we saw before.
We would like to understand,
is this a good parallel
program or not?
Based on if I understand
the logical
parallelism that I've exposed.
So how much parallelism do
you think is in here?
Give me a number.
How many processors does it
make sense to run this on?
Five?
That's as parallel as it gets.
Let's take a look.
We're going to do an analysis.
At the end of it, we'll know
what the answer is.
So for that, let tp be the
execution time on p processors
for this particular program.
It turns but there
are two measures
that are really important.
The first is called the work.
OK, so of course, we know
that real machines
have caches, etc.
Let's forget all of that.
Just very simple algorithmic
model where every strand,
let's say, costs us unit time
as opposed to in practice,
they may be many instructions
and so forth.
We can take that into account.
Let's take that into
account separately.
So T1 is the work.
It's the time it if I had to
execute it on one processor,
I've got to do all the
work that's in here.
So what's the work of this
particular computation?
I think it's 18, right?
Yeah, 18.
So T1 is the work.
So even though I'm executing a
parallel, I could it execute
it serially and then T1 is the
amount of work it would take.
The other measure is called the
span, and sometimes called
critical path length or
computational depth.
And it corresponds to the
longest path of dependencies
in the DAG.
We call it T infinity because
even if you had an infinite
number of processors, you still
can't do this one until
you finish that one.
You can't do this one until you
finish that one, can't do
this one till you've finished
that one and so forth.
So even with an infinite number
of processors, I still
wouldn't go faster
than the span.
So that's why we denote
by T infinity.
So these are the two
important measures.
Now what we're really
interested in is
Tp for a given p.
As you'll see, we actually can
get some bounds on the
performance on p processors just
by looking at the work,
the span and the number of
processors we're executing on.
So the first bound is
the following, it's
called the Work Law.
The Work Law says that the time
on p processors is at
least the time on one processor
divided by p.
So why does that Work
Law make sense?
What's that saying?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Like work is
conserved sort of?
I mean, you have to do the
same amount of work.
PROFESSOR: You have to do the
same amount of work, so on
every time step, you can get
p pieces of work done.
So if you're running for fewer
than T1 over p steps, you've
done less than T1 work
over and time Tp.
So you won't have done all
the work if you run
for less than this.
So the time must be at least
Tp, time Tp must be at
least T1 over p.
You only get to do p
work on one step.
Is that pretty clear?
The second one should be even
clearer, the Span Law.
On p processors, you're not
going to go faster than if you
had an infinite number of
processors because the
infinite processor could always
use fewer processors if
it's scheduled.
Once again, this is a
very simple model.
We're not taking into account
scheduling, we're not taking
into account overheads or
whatever, just a simple
conceptual model for
understanding parallelism.
So any questions about
these two laws?
There's going to be a couple
of formulas in this lecture
today that you should write
down and play with.
So these two, they may seem
simple, but these are hugely
important formulas.
So you should know that Tp is at
least T1 over p, that's the
Work Law and that Tp is
at least T infinity.
Those are bounds on how fast
you could execute.
Do I have a question
in that back there?
OK so let's see what happens
to work in span in terms of
how we can understand our
programs and decompose them.
So suppose that I have a
computation A followed by
computation B and I connect
them in series.
What happens to the work?
How does the work of all this
whole thing correspond to the
work of A and the work of B?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, add
them together.
You get T1 of A plus T1 of B.
Take the work of this and the
work of this.
OK, that's pretty easy.
What about the span?
So the span is the longest
path of dependencies.
What happens to the span
when I connect
two things in a series?
Yeah, it just sums as well
because I take whatever the
longest path is from here to
here and then the longest one
from here to here,
it just adds.
But now let's look at parallel
composition, So now suppose
that I can execute these
two things in parallel.
What happens to the work?
It just adds, just as before.
The work always adds.
The work is easy because
it's additive.
What happens to the span?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's the
max of the spans.
Right, so whatever is the
longest, whichever one of
these ones has a longer span,
that's going to be
the span of the total.
Does that give you some
Intuition So we're going to
see when we analyze the spans of
things that in fact, we're
going to see maxes occurring
all over the place.
So speedup is defined
to be T1 over Tp.
So speedup is how much faster am
I on p processors than I am
on one processor?
Pretty easy.
So if T1 over Tp is equal to
p, we say we have perfect
linear speedup, or
linear speedup.
That's good, right?
Because if I put on use p
processors, I'd like to have
things go p times faster.
OK, that would be
the ideal world.
If T1 over Tp, which is the
speedup, is greater than p,
that says we have super
linear speedup.
And in our model, we don't get
that because of the work law.
Because the work law says Tp is
greater than or equal to T1
over p and just do a little
algebra here, you get T1 over
Tp must be less than
or equal to p.
So you can't get super
linear speedup.
In practice, there are
situations where you can get
super linear speedup due
to caching effects and
a variety of things.
We'll talk about some
of those things.
But in this simple model,
we don't get
that kind of behavior.
And of course, the case I left
out is the common case, which
is the T1 over Tp is less than
p, and that's very common
people write code which doesn't
give them linear speedup.
We're mostly interested in
getting linear speedup here.
That's our goal.
So that we're getting the most
bang for the buck out of the
processors we're using.
OK, parallelism.
So we're finally to the point
where I can talk about
parallelism and give a
quantitative definition of
parallelism.
So the Span Law says that Tp is
at least T infinity, right?
The time on p processors is at
least the time on an infinite
number of processors.
So the maximum possible speedup,
that's T1 over Tp,
given T1 and T infinity
is T1 over T infinity.
And we call that the
parallelism.
It's the maximum amount
of speedup we
could possibly attain.
So we have the speedup and the
speedup by the Span Law that
says this is the maximum amount
we can get, we could
also view it as if I look along
the critical path of the
computation.
It's sort of what's the average
amount of work at
every level.
The work, the total amount of
stuff here divided by that
length there that sort of tells
us the width, what's the
average amount of stuff that's
going on in every step.
So for this example,
what is the--
I forgot to put this
on my slide--
what is the parallelism of
this particular DAG here?
Two, right?
So the span has length nine--
this is assuming everything
was unit time--
obviously in reality, when you
have more instructions, you in
fact would make it be whatever
the length of this was in
terms of number of instructions
or what have you,
of execution time of
all these things.
So this is length 9, there's
18 things here,
parallelism is 2.
So we can quantify parallelism
precisely.
We'll see why it's important
to quantify it.
So that the maximum speedup
we're going to get when we run
this application.
Here's another example
we did before.
Fib of four.
So let's assume again that
each strand takes
unit time to execute.
So what is the work in this
particular computation?
Assume every strand takes unit
time to execute, which of
course it doesn't, but--
anybody care to hazard
a guess?
17, yeah, because there's four
nodes here that have 3 plus 5.
So 3 times 4 plus 5 is 17.
So the work is 17.
OK, what's the span?
This one's tricky.
Too bad it's not a little
bit more focused.
What the span?
AUDIENCE: 8.
PROFESSOR: 8, that's correct.
Who got 7?
Yeah, so I got 7 when I did this
and then I looked harder
and it was 8.
It's 8, so here it is.
Here's the span.
There is goes.
Ooh that little sidestep there,
that's what makes it 8.
OK so basically, it comes down
here and I had gone down like
that when I did it, but in fact,
you've got to go over
and back up.
So it's actually 8.
So that says that the
parallelism is a little bit
more than 2, 2 and 1/8.
What that says is that if
I use many more than two
processors, I can't get linear
speedup anymore.
I'm only going to get marginal
performance gains.
If I use more than 2, because
the maximum speedup I can get
is like 2.125 if I had an
infinite number of processors.
So any questions about this?
So this by the way deceptively
simple and yet, if you don't
play around with it a little
bit, you can get
confused very easily.
Deceptively simple,
very powerful to
be able to do this.
So here we have for the analysis
of parallelism, one
of the things that we have going
for us in using the Cilk
tool suite is a program called
Cilkview, which has a
scalability analyzer.
And it is like the race detector
that I talked to you
about last time in that it uses
dynamic instrumentation.
So you run it under Cilkview,
it's like running it under
[? Valgrhen ?]
for example, or what have you.
So basically you run your
program under it, and it
analyzes your program
for scalability.
It computes the work and span of
your program to derive some
upper bounds on parallel
performance and it also
estimates a scheduling overhead
to compute what's
called a burden span
for lower bounds.
So let's take a look.
So here's, for example, here's
a quick sort program.
So let's just see this
is a c++ program.
So here we're using a template
so that the type of items that
I'm sorting I can make
be a variable.
So tightening-- can we shut
the back door there?
One of the TAs?
Somebody run up to--
thank you.
So we have the variable T And
we're going to quick sort from
the beginning to the
end of the array.
And what we do is, just as
you're familiar with quick
sort, if there's actually
something to be sorted, more
than one thing, then we find the
middle by partitioning the
thing and this is a bit
of a c++ magic to
find the middle element.
And then the important part
from our point of view is
after we've done this partition,
we quick sort the
first part of the array, from
beginning to middle and then
from the beginning plus 1 or
the middle, whichever is
greater to the end.
And then we sync.
So what we're doing is quick
sort where we're spawning off
the two sub problems to
be solved in parallel
recursively.
So they're going to execute in
parallel and they're going to
execute in parallel
and so forth.
So a fairly natural thing to
divide, to do divide and
conquer on quick sort because
the two some problems can be
operated on independently.
We just sort them recursively.
But we can sort them
in parallel.
OK, so suppose that we are
sorting 100,000 numbers.
How much parallelism do you
think is in this code?
So remember that we're getting
this recursive stuff done.
How many people think--
well, it's not going
to be more than
100,000, I promise you.
So how many people think more
than a million parallels?
Raise your hand, more
than a million?
And how many people think
more than 100,000?
more than 10,000?
OK, between the two.
More than 1,000?
OK, how about more than 100?
100 to 1,000?
How about 10 to 100?
How about between 1 and 10?
So a lot of people think
between 1 and 10.
Why do you think that there's
so little parallels in this?
You don't have to justify
yourself, OK.
Well let's see how much there
is according to Cilkview.
So here's the type of output
that you'll get.
You'll get a graphical curve.
You'll also get a
textual output.
But this is sort of the
graphical output.
And this is basically showing
what the running time here is.
So the first thing it shows is
it will actually run your
program, benchmark your program,
on in this case, up
to 8 course.
We ran it.
So we ran up to 8 course and
give you what your measured
speedup is.
So the second thing is it
tells you the parallels.
If you can't read that
it's, 11.21.
So we get about 11.
Why do you think it's
not higher?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's the log.
PROFESSOR: What's the log?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but you're
doing the two things in
parallel, right?
We'll actually analyze this.
So it has to do with the fact
that the partition routine is
a serial piece of code
and it's big.
So the initial partitioning
takes you 100,000--
sorry, 100 million steps
of doing a partition--
before you get to do any
parallelism at all.
And we'll see that
in just a minute.
So it gives you the
parallelism.
It also plots this.
So this is the parallelism.
Notice that's the same
number, 11.21 is
plotted as this bound.
So it tells you the span law and
it tells you the work law.
This is the linear speedup.
If you were having linear
speedup, this is what your
program would give you.
So it gives you these two
bounds, the work law and span
law on your speedup.
And then it also computes
what's called a burden
parallelism, estimating
scheduling overheads to sort
of give you a lower bound.
Now that's not to say that
your numbers can't fall
outside this range.
But when they do, it will tell
you essentially what the
issues are with your program.
And we'll discuss how you
diagnose some of those issues.
Actually that's in one of the
handouts that we've provided.
I think that's in one
of the handouts.
If not, we'll make sure it's
among the handouts.
So basically, this gives you a
range for what you can expect.
So the important thing here is
to notice here for example,
that we're losing performance,
but it's not due to the
parallelism, to the work law.
Basically, in some sense, what's
happening is we are
losing it because the Span Law
because we're starting to
approach the point where the
span is going to be the issue.
So we'll talk more about this.
So the main thing is you have
a tool that can tell you the
work and span and so that you
can analyze your own programs
to understand are you bounded
by parallelism, for example,
in particular, in the code
that you've written.
OK let's do a theoretical
analysis of this to understand
why that number is small.
So the main thing here is that
the expected work, as you
recall, of quick sort
is order n log n.
You tend to do order n log n
work, you partition and then
you're solving two problems
of the same size.
If you actually draw out the
recursion tree, it's log
height with linear amount of
work on every level for n log
end total work.
The expected span, however, is
order n because the partition
routine is a serial program that
partitions up the thing
of size n in order n time.
So when you compute the
parallelism, you get
parallelism of order log n
and log n is kind of puny
parallelism, and that's our
technical word for it.
So puny parallelism is what
we get out of quick sort.
So it turns out there
are lots of things
that you can analyze.
Here's just a selection of
some of the interesting
practical algorithms and the
kinds of analyses that you can
do showing that, for example,
with merge sort you can do it
with work n log n.
You can get a span of log qn and
so then the parallelism is
the ratio of the two.
In fact, you can actually
theoretically get log squared
n span, but that's not as
practical an algorithm as the
one that gives you
log cubed n.
And you can go through and there
are a whole bunch of
algorithms for which you can
get very good parallelism.
So all of these, if you look
at the ratio of these, the
parallelism is quite high.
So let's talk a little bit
about what's going on
underneath and why parallelism
is important.
So when you describe your
program in Cilk, you express
the potential parallelism
of your application.
You don't say exactly how it's
going to be scheduled, that's
done by the Cilk++ scheduler,
which maps the strands
dynamically onto the processors
at run time.
So it's going to do the load
balancing and everything
necessary to balance your
computation off the number of
processors.
We want to understand how that
process works, because that's
going to help us to understand
how it is that we can build
codes that will map very
effectively on to the number
of processors.
Now it turns out that the theory
of the distributed
schedulers such as is in
Cilk++ is complicated.
I'll wave my hands about it
towards the end, but the
analysis of it is advanced.
You have to take a graduate
course to get that stuff.
So instead, we're going to
explore the ideas with a
centralized, much simpler,
scheduler which serves as a
surrogate for understanding
what's going on.
So the basic idea of almost all
scheduling theory in this
domain is greedy scheduling.
And so this is-- by the way,
we're coming to the second
thing you have to understand
really well in order to be
able to generate good code,
the second sort
of theoretical thing--
so the idea of a greedy
scheduler is you want to do as
much work as possible
on each step.
So the idea here is let's take
a look, for example, suppose
that we've executed this part
of the DAG already.
Then there are certain number
of strands that are ready to
execute, meaning all their
predecessors have exited.
How many strands are ready
to execute on this DAG?
Five, right?
These guys.
So those five strands are
ready to execute.
So the idea is-- and let me
illustrate for p equals 3--
the idea is to understand the
execution in terms of two
types of steps.
So in a greed schedule, you
always do as much as possible.
So is what would be called a
complete step because I can
schedule all three processors
to have some work
to do on that step.
So which are the best three guys
to be able to execute?
Yes, so I'm not sure what the
best three are, but for sure,
you want to get this guy
and this guy, right?
Maybe that guy's not,
but this guy, you
definitely want to execute.
And these guys, I guess, OK.
So in a greedy schedule, no,
you're not allowed to look to
see which ones are
the best execute.
You don't know what the future
is, the scheduler isn't going
to know what the future is so it
just executes any p course.
You just execute any p course.
In this case, I executed
the p strand.
In this case, I executed these
three guys even though they
weren't necessarily the best.
And in a greedy scheduler, it
doesn't look to see what's the
best one to execute, it
just executes as many
as it can this case.
In this case, it's p.
Now we have what's called
an incomplete step.
Notice nothing got enabled.
That was sort of too bad.
So there's only two guys
that are ready to go.
What do you think happens if
I have an incomplete step,
namely p strands are
ready, fewer than
p strands are ready?
I just to execute all of
them, as many as I can.
Run all of them.
So that's what a greedy
scheduler does.
Just at every step, it executes
as many as it can and
we can classify the steps as
ones which are complete,
meaning we used all our
processors versus incomplete,
meaning we only used a subset
of our processors in
scheduling it.
So that's what a greedy
scheduler does.
Now the important thing,
which is the
analysis of this program.
And this is, by the way, the
single most important thing in
scheduling theory but you're
going to ever learn is this
particular theory.
It goes all the way back to
1968 and what it basically
says it is any greedy scheduler
achieves a bound of
T1 over p plus T infinity.
So why is that an interesting
upper bound?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That says that it's
got the refinement of what you
said before, even if you add as
many processors as you can,
basically you're bounded
by T infinity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's compulsory.
PROFESSOR: So basically, each
of these, this term here is
the term in the Work Law.
This is the term in the Span
Law, and we're saying you can
always achieve the sum of those
two lower bounds as an
upper bound.
So let's see how we do this and
then we'll look at some of
the implications.
Question, do you have
a question?
No?
So here's the proof that
you meet this.
So that the proof says--
and I'll illustrate
for P equals 3--
how many complete steps
could we have?
So I'll argue that the number
of complete steps is at
most T1 over p.
Why is that?
Every complete step
performs p work.
So if I had more complete steps
than T1 over p, I'd be
doing more than T1 work.
But I only have T1 work to do.
OK, so the maximum number of
complete steps I could have is
at most T1 over p.
Do people follow that?
So the trickier part of the
proof, which is not all that
tricky but it's a little bit
trickier, is the other side.
How many incomplete steps
could I have?
So we execute those.
So I claim that the number of
incomplete steps is bounded by
the critical path length,
by the span.
Why is that?
Well let's take a look at
the part of DAG that
has yet to be executed.
So that this gray part here.
There's some span associated
with that.
In this case, it's this
longest path.
When I execute all of the ready
threads that are ready
to go, I guarantee to reduce
the span of that unexecuted
DAG by at least one.
So as I do here, so I reduce
it by one when I execute.
So if I have a complete step,
I don't guaranteed to reduce
the span of the unexecuted DAG,
because I may execute
things as I showed you in this
example, you don't actually
advance anything.
But I execute all the ready
threads on an incomplete step,
and that's going to
reduce it by one.
So the number of incomplete
steps is at most infinity.
So the total number of steps
is at most the sum.
So as I say, this proof you
should understand in your
sleep because it's the most
important scheduling theory
proof that you're going to
probably see in your lifetime.
It's very old, and really, very,
very simple and yet,
there's a huge amount of
scheduling theory if you have
a look at scheduling theory,
that comes out of this just
making this same problem more
complicated and more real and
more interesting and so forth.
But this is really the crux
of what's going on.
Any questions about
this proof?
So one corollary of the greedy
scheduling algorithm is that
any greedy scheduler achieves
within a factor of two of
optimal scheduling.
So let's see why that is.
So it's guaranteed as an upper
bound to get within a factor
of two of optimal.
So here's the proof.
So let's Tp star be the
execution time produced by the
optimal scheduler.
This is the schedule that knows
the whole DAG in advance
and can schedule things exactly
where they need to be
scheduled to minimize the
total amount of time.
Now even though the optimal
scheduler can schedule very
officially, it's still
bound by the Work Law
and the Span Law.
So therefore, Tp star has still
got to be greater than
T1 over p and greater than
T infinity by the
Work and Span Laws.
Even though it's optimal, every
scheduler must obey the
Work Laws and Spam Law.
So then we have, by the greedy
scheduling theorem, Tp is at
most T1 over p plus
T infinity.
Well that's at most twice the
maximum of these two values,
whichever is larger.
I've just plugged in to get the
maximum of those two and
that's at most, by
this equation,
twice the optimal time.
So this is a very simple
corollary says oh, greedy
scheduling is actually
pretty good.
It's not optimal,
in fact, optimal
scheduling is mP complete.
Very hard problem to solve.
But getting within a factor
of two, you just do greedy
scheduling, it works
just fine.
More importantly is the next
corollary, which has to do is
when do you get linear
speedup?
And this is, I think, the
most important thing
to get out of this.
So any greedy scheduler achieves
near perfect linear
speedup whenever--
what's this thing on
the left-hand side?
What's the name we
call that?--
the parallelism, right?
That's the parallelism, is much
bigger than the number of
processors you're running on.
So if the number of processors
are running on is smaller than
the parallelism of your code
says you can expect near
perfect linear speedup.
OK, so what does that say you
want to do in your program?
You want to make sure you have
ample parallelism and then the
scheduler will be able to
schedule it so that you get
near perfect linear speedup.
Let's see why that's true.
So T1 over T infinity is much
bigger than p is equivalent to
saying that T infinity is much
less than T1 over p.
That's just algebra.
Well what does that mean?
The greedy scheduling theorem
says Tp is at most T1 over p
plus T infinity.
We just said that if we have
this condition, then T
infinity is very small compared
to T1 over p.
So if this is negligible,
then the whole thing is
about T1 over p.
Well that just says that
the speedup is about p.
So the name of the game is to
make sure that your span is
relatively short compared to
the amount of work per
processor that you're doing.
And in that case, you'll
get linear speedup.
And that happens when you've
got enough parallelism
compared to the number
processors you're running on.
Any questions about this?
This is like the most important
thing you're going
to learn about parallel
computing.
Everything else we're going to
do is going to be derivatives
of this, so if you don't
understand this, you have a
hard time with the
other stuff.
So in some sense, it's
deceptively simple, right?
We just have a few variables,
T1, Tp, T infinity, p, there's
not much else going on.
But there are these bounds and
these elegant theorems that
tell us something about how no
matter what the shape of the
DAG is or whatever, these two
values, the work and the span,
really characterize very closely
where it is that you
can expect to get
linear speedup.
Any questions?
OK, good.
So the quantity T1 over PT
infinity, so what is that?
That's just the parallelism
divided by p.
That's called the parallel
slackness.
So this parallel slackness is
10, means you have 10 times
more parallelism than
processors.
So if you have high slackness,
you can expect
to get linear speedup.
If you have low slackness,
don't expect
to get linear speedup.
OK.
Now the scheduler we're using
is not a greedy scheduler.
It's better in many ways,
because it's a distributed,
what's called work stealing
scheduler and I'll show you
how it works in a little bit.
But it's based on
the same theory.
Even though it's a more
complicated scheduler from an
analytical point of view, it's
really based on the same
theory as greedy scheduling.
It guarantees that the time on
p processors is at most T1
over p plus order T infinity.
So there's a constant here.
And it's a randomized scheduler,
so it actually only
guarantees this in
expectation.
It actually guarantees very
close to this with high
probability.
OK so the difference is the big
O, but if you look at any
of the formulas that we did with
the greedy scheduler, the
fact that there's a constant
there doesn't really matter.
You get the same effect, it just
means that the slackness
that you need to get linear
speedup has to not only
overcome the T infinity, it's
also got to overcome the
constant there.
And empirically, it actually
turns out this is not bad as
an estimate using the
greedy bound.
Not bad as an estimate, so this
is sort of a model that
we'll take as if we're
doing things
with a greedy scheduler.
And that will be very close for
what we're actually going
to see in practice with
the Cilk++ scheduler.
So once again, it means near
perfect linear speedup as long
as p is much less than T1 over
T infinity generally.
And so Cilkview allows us to
measure T1 and T infinity.
So that's going to be good,
because then we can figure out
what our parallelism is and look
to see how we're running
on typically 12 cores, how much
parallels do we have?
If our parallelism is 12, we
don't have a lot of slackness.
We won't get very
good speedup.
But if we have a parallelism
of say, 10 times more, say
120, we should get very, very
good parallelism, very, very
good speedup on 12 cores.
We should get close to
perfect speedup.
So let's talk about the runtime
system and how this
work stealing scheduler works,
because it different
from the other one.
And this will be helpful also
for understanding when you
program these things what
you can expect.
So the basic idea of the
schedule is there's two
strategies the people have
explored for doing scheduling.
One is called work sharing,
which is not what Cilk++ does.
But let me explain what work
sharing is because it's
helpful to contrast it
with work stealing.
So in works sharing, what you do
is when you spawn off some
work, you say let me go find
some low utilized processor
and put that worked there
for it to operate on.
The problem with work sharing
is that you have to do some
communication and
synchronization every time you
do a spawn.
Every time you do a spawn,
you're going to go out.
This is kind of what
Pthreads does, when
you do Pthread create.
It goes out and says OK, let me
create all of the things it
needs to do and get it schedule
then on a processor.
Work stealing, on the
other hand, takes
the opposite approach.
Whenever it spawns work, it's
just going to keep that work
local to it, but make it
available for stealing.
A processor that runs out of
work is going to go looking
for work to steal,
to bring back.
The advantage of work stealing
is that the processor doesn't
do any synchronization
except when it's
actually load balancing.
So if all of the processors have
ample work to do, then
what happens is there's no
overhead for scheduling
whatsoever.
They all just crank away.
And so you get very, very low
overheads when there's ample
work to do on each processor.
So let's see how this works.
So the particular way that
it maintains it is that
basically, each processor
maintains a work deck.
So a deck is a double-ended
queue of the ready strands.
It manipulates the bottom of
the deck like a stack.
So what that says is, for
example, here, we had a spawn
followed by two calls.
And basically, it's operating
just as it would have to
operate in an ordinary stack,
an ordinary call stack.
So, for example, this guy says
call, well it pushes a frame
on the bottom of the call
stack just like normal.
It says spawn, it pushes
a spawn frame on the
bottom of the deck.
In fact, of course, it's running
in parallel, so you
can have a bunch of guys that
are both calling and spawning
and they all push whatever
their frames are.
When somebody says return,
you just pop it off.
So in the common case, each of
these guys is just executing
the code serially the way
that it would normally
executing in C or C++.
However, if somebody runs out
of work, then it becomes a
thief and it looks for a victim
and the strategy that's
used by Cilk++ is to
look at random.
It says let me just go to
any other processor
or any other workers--
I call these workers--
and grab away some
of their work.
But when it grabs it away, what
it does is it steals it
from the opposite end of the
deck from where this
particular victim is actually
doing its work.
So it steals the oldest
stuff first.
So it moves that over and now
here what it's doing is it's
stealing up to the point
that it spawns.
So it steals from the top of the
deck down to where there's
a spawn on top.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there always
a spawn on the
top of every deck?
PROFESSOR: Close,
almost always.
Yes, so I think that you could
say that there are.
So the initial deck does not
have a spawn on top of it, but
you could imagine that it did.
And then when you steal, you're
always stealing from
the top down to a spawn.
If there isn't something, if
this is just a call here, this
cannot any longer be stolen.
There's no work there to be
stolen because this is just a
single execution, there's
nothing that's been spawned
off at this point.
This is the result of having
been spawned as opposed to
that it's doing a spawn.
So yes, basically
you're right.
There's a spawn on the top.
So it basically steals that
off and then it resumes
execution afterwards and starts
then operating just
like an ordinary deck.
So the theorem that you can
prove for this type of
scheduler is that if you have
sufficient parallelism, so you
all know what parallelism is at
this point, you can prove
that the workers steal
infrequently.
So in a a typical execution, you
might have a few hundred
load balancing operations of
this nature for something
which is doing billions and
billions of instructions.
So you steal infrequently.
If you're stealing infrequently
and all the rest
of the time you're just
executing like the C or C++,
hey, now you've got linear
speedup because you've got all
of these guys working
all the time.
And so as I say, the main thing
to understand is that
there's this work stealing
scheduler running underneath.
It's more complicated to
analyze then the greedy
scheduler, but it gives you
pretty much the same
qualitative kinds of results.
And the idea then is that the
stealing occurs infrequently
so you get linear speedup.
So the idea then is just as with
greedy scheduling, make
sure you have enough
parallelism, because then the
load balancing is a small
fraction of the time these
processors are spending
executing the code.
Because whenever it's doing
things like work stealing,
it's not working on your code
executing, making it go fast.
It's doing bookkeeping and
overhead and stuff.
So you want to make sure
that stays low.
So any questions about that?
So specifically, we
have these bounds.
You have achieved this expected
running time, which I
mentioned before.
Let me give you a pseudo-proof
of this.
So this is not a real proof
because it ignores things like
independence of probabilities.
So when you do a probability
analysis, you're not allowed
to multiply probabilities unless
they're independent.
So anyway, here I'm multiplying
probabilities that
are independent.
So the idea is you can
view a processor as
either working or stealing.
So it goes into one
of two modes.
It's going to be stealing
if it's run out of work,
otherwise it's working.
So the total time all processors
spend working is
T1, hooray, that's
at least a bound.
Now it turns out that every
steal has a 1 over p chance of
reducing the span by one.
So you can prove that of all of
the work that's in the top
of all those decks that those
are where any of the ready
threads are going to be there
are in a position of reducing
the span if you execute them.
And so whenever you steal, you
have a 1 over p chance of
hitting the guy that matters
for the span
of unexecuted DAG.
So the same kind of thing
as in theory.
You have a 1 over p chance.
So the expected cost of all
steals is order PT infinity.
So this is true, but not
for this reason.
But it's kind, the intuition
is right.
So therefore the cost of all
steals is PT infinity and the
cost of the work is T1, so
that's the total amount of
work and time spent stealing
by all the p processors.
So to get the time spent doing
that, we divide by p, because
they're p processors.
And when I do that, I get T1
over p plus order T infinity.
So that's kind of where that
bound is coming from.
So you can see what's important
here is that the
term, that order T infinity
term, this the one where all
the overhead of scheduling
and synchronization is.
There's no overhead for
scheduling and synchronization
in the T1 over p term.
The only overhead there is to do
things like mark the frames
as being a steel frame or
a spawn frame and do the
bookkeeping of the deck as
you're executing so the spawn
can be implemented
very cheaply.
Now in addition to the
scheduling things, there are
some other things to understand
a little bit about
the scheduler and that is that
it supports the C, C++ rule
for pointers.
So remember in C and C++, you
can pass a pointer to stack
space down, but you can't pass
a pointer to stack space back
to your parent, right?
Because it popped off.
So if you think about a C or
C++ execution, let's say we
have this call structure here.
A really cannot see any of the
stack space of B,C,D or E. So
this is what A gets to see.
And B, meanwhile, can see A
space, because that's down on
the stack, but it can't see C, D
or E. Particularly if you're
executing this serially, it
can't see C because C hasn't
executed yet when B executes.
However, C, it turns out,
the same thing.
I can't see any of the variables
that might be
allocated in the space
for B when I'm
executing here on a stack.
You can see them in a heap, but
not on the stack, because
B has been popped off at that
point and so forth.
So this is basically the normal
rule, the normal views
of stack that you
get in C or C++.
In Cilk++, you get exactly the
same behavior except that
multiple ones of these views
may exist at the same time.
So if, for example, B and C are
both executing at the same
time, they each will
see their own stack
space and a stack space.
And so the cactus stack
maintains that fiction that
you can sort of look at your
ancestors and see your
ancestors, but now
it's maintained.
It's called a cactus stack
because it's kind of like a
tree structure upside down, like
a what's the name of that
big cactus out West?
Yes, saguaro.
The saguaro cactus, yep.
This kind of looks like that
if you look at the stacks.
This leads to a very powerful
bound on how much space your
program is using.
So normally, if you do a greedy
scheduler, you could
end up using gobs more space
then you would in a serial
execution, gobs more
stack space.
In Cilk++ programs,
you have a bound.
It's p times s1 is the maximum
amount of stack space you'll
ever use where s1 is
the stack space
used by serial execution.
So if you can keep your serial
execution to use a reasonable
amount of stack space--
and usually it does--
then in parallel, you don't
use more than p times that
amount of stack space.
And the proof for that is sort
of by induction, which
basically says there's a
property called the Busy
Leaves Property that says that
if you have a leaf that's
being worked on but hasn't
been completed--
so I've indicated those by the
purple and pink ones--
then if it's a leaf, it has
a worker executing on it.
And so therefore, if you look at
how much stack space you're
using, each of these guys can
trace up and they may double
count the stack space, but it'll
still be bounded by p
times the depth that they're
at, or p times s1, which is
the maximum amount.
So it has good space bounds.
That's not so crucial for you
folks to know as a practical
matter, but it would be
if this didn't hold.
If this didn't hold, then you
would have more programming
problems than you'll have.
The implications of this work
stealing scheduler is
interesting from the linguistic
point of view,
because you can write a code
like this, so for i gets one
to a billion, spawn some
sub-routine foo
of i and then sync.
So one way of executing this,
the way that the work sharing
schedulers tend to do this,
is they say oh, I've got a
billion tasks to do.
So let me create a billion tasks
and now schedule them
and the space just vrooms to
store all those billion tasks,
it gets to be huge.
Now of course, they have some
strategies they can use to
reduce it by bunching tasks
together and so forth.
But in principle, you got a
billion pieces of work to do
even if you execute
on one processor.
Whereas in the work stealing
type execution, what happens
is you execute this in
fact depth research.
So basically, you're going to
execute foo of 1 and then
you'll return.
And then you'll increment i and
you'll execute foo of 2,
and you'll return.
At no time are you using more
than in this case two stack
frames, one for this routine
here and one for foo because
you basically keep going up.
You're using your stack up on
demand, rather than creating
all the work up front
to be scheduled.
So the work stealing scheduler
is very good from
that point of view.
The tricky thing for people
to understand is that if
executing on multiple
processors, when you do Cilk
spawn, the processor, the worker
that you're running on,
is going to execute foo of 1.
The next statement--
which would basically
be incrementing the
counter and so forth--
is executed by whatever
processor comes in and steals
that continuation.
So if you had two processors,
they're each going to
basically be executing.
The first processor isn't the
one that excuse everything in
this function.
This function has its execution
shared, the strands
are going to be shared where the
first part of it would be
done by processor one and the
latter part of it would be
done by processor two.
And then when processor one
finishes this off, it might go
back and steal back from
processor two.
So the important thing there is
it's generating its stack
needs sort of on demand rather
than all up front, and that
keeps the amount of stack space
small as it executes.
So the moral is it's better to
steal your parents from their
children than stealing children
from their parents.
So that's the advantage of
doing this sort of parent
stealing, because you're always
doing the frame which
is an ancestor of where that
worker is working and that
means resuming a function
right in the middle on a
different processor.
That's kind of the magic of the
technologies is how do you
actually move a stack frame from
one place to another and
resume it in the middle?
Let's finish up here with
a chess lesson.
I promised a chess lesson,
so we might as well do
some fun and games.
We have a lot of experience at
MIT with chess programs.
We've had a lot of success,
probably our closest one was
Star Socrates 2.0, which took
second place in the world
computer chess championship
running on an 1824 node Intel
Paragon, so a big supercomputer
running with a
Cilk scheduler.
We actually almost won that
competition, and it's a sad
story that maybe be sometime
around dinner or something I
will tell you the sad story
behind it, but I'm not going
to tell you why we didn't
take first place.
And we've had a bunch of other
successes over the years.
Right now our chess programming
is dormant, we're
not doing that in my group
anymore, but in the past, we
had some very strong chess
playing programs.
So what we did with Star
Socrates, which is one of our
programs, was we wanted to
understand the Cilk scheduler.
And so what we did is we ran
a whole bunch of different
positions on different numbers
of processors which ran for
different amounts of time.
We wanted to plot them all on
the same chart, and here's our
strategy for doing it.
What decided to do was do a
standard speedup curve.
So a standard speedup curve says
let's plot the number of
processors along this axis and
the speed up along that axis.
But in order to fit all these
things on the same processor
curve, what we did was we
normalize the speedup.
So what's the maximum pot?
So here's the speedup.
If you look the numerator
here, this is the
speedup, T1 over Tp.
What we did is we normalized
by the parallelism.
So we said what fraction of
perfect speedup can we get?
So here one says that I got
exactly a speedup, this is the
maximum possible speed up that
I can get because the maximum
possible value of T1 over
p is T1 over T infinity.
So that's sort of the maximum.
On this axis, we said how
many processors are
you running on it?
Well, we looked at
that relative to
essentially the slackness.
So notice by normalizing, we
essentially have here the
inverse of the slackness.
So 1 here says that I'm running
on exactly the same
number of processors
as my parallelism.
A tenth here says I've got a
slackness of 10, I'm running
on 10 times fewer processors
then parallelism.
Out here, I'm saying I got way
more processors than I have
parallelism.
So I plotted all the points.
So it doesn't show up very well
here, but all those green
points, there are a lot of green
points here, that's our
performance, measured
performance.
You can sort of see they're
green there, not the best
color for this projector.
So we plot on this essentially
the Work Law and the Span Law.
So this is the Work Law, it says
linear speedup, and this
is the Span Law.
And you can see that we're
getting very close to perfect
linear speedup as long as our
slackness is 10 or greater.
See that?
It's hugging that curve
really tightly.
As we approach a slackness of 1,
you can see that it starts
to go away from the linear
speedup curve.
So for this program, if you
look, it says, gee, if we were
running with 10 time, slackness
of 10, 10 times more
parallelism than processors,
we're getting almost perfect
linear speedup in the number of
processors we're running on
across a wide range of number
of processors, wide range of
benchmarks for this
chess program.
And in fact, this curve
is the curve.
This is not an interpolation
here, but rather it is just
the greedy scheduling curve,
and you can see it does a
pretty good job of going through
all the points here.
Greedy scheduling does a pretty
good job of predicting
the performance.
The other thing you should
notice is that although things
are very tight down here, as
you approach up here, they
start getting more spread.
And the reason is that as you
start having more of the span
mattering in the calculation,
that's where all the
synchronization, communication,
all the
overhead of actually doing the
mechanics of moving a frame
from one processor to another
take into account, so you get
a lot more spread as
you go up here.
So that's just the first
part of the lesson.
The first part was, oh, the
theory works out in practice
for real programs.
You have like 10 times more
parallelisms than processors,
you're going to do a
pretty good job of
getting linear speedup.
So that says you guys should be
shooting for parallelisms
on the order of 100 for
running on 12 cores.
Somewhere in that vicinity you
should be doing pretty well if
you've got parallelism
of 100 when you
measure it for your codes.
So we normalize by the
parallel there.
Now the real lesson though was
understanding how to use
things like work and span to
make decisions in the design
of our program.
So as it turned out, Socrates
for this particular
competition was to run on a
512 processor connection
machine at the University
of Illinois.
So this was in the mid
in the early 1990's.
It was one of the most powerful
machines in the
world, and this thing is
probably more powerful today.
But in those days, it was a
pretty powerful machine.
I don't know whether this
thing is, but this thing
probably I'm pretty sure
is more powerful.
So this was a big machine.
However here at MIT, we didn't
have a great big
machine like that.
We only had a 32
processor CM5.
So we were developing on a
little machine expecting to
run on a big machine.
So one of the developers
proposed to change the program
that produced a speedup of over
20% on the MIT machine.
So we said, oh that's pretty
good, 25% improvement.
But we did a back of the
envelope calculation and
rejected that improvement
because we were able to use
work and span to predict the
behavior on the big machine.
So let's see how that worked
out, why that worked out.
So I've fudged these numbers so
that they're easy to do the
math on and easy
to understand.
The real numbers actually though
did sort out very, very
similar to what I'm saying,
just they weren't round
numbers like I'm going
to give you.
So the original program
ran for let's say 65
seconds on 32 cores.
The proposed program ran for
40 seconds on 32 cores.
Sounds like a good improvement
to me.
Let's go for the
faster program.
Well, let's hold your horses.
Let's take a look at our
performance model based on
greedy scheduling.
That Tp is T1 over
p plus infinity.
What component we really need to
understand the scale this,
what component of each of
these things is work
and which is span?
Because that's how we're going
to be able to predict what's
going to happen on
the big machine.
So indeed, this original program
had a work of 2048
seconds and a span
of one second.
Now chess, it turns out, is a
non-deterministic type of
program where you use
speculative parallelism, and
so in order to get more
parallelism, you can sacrifice
and do more work versus
less work.
So this one over here that we
improved it to had less work
on the benchmark, but it
had a longer span.
So it had less work
but a longer span.
So when we actually were going
to run this, well first of
all, we did the calculation
and it actually came out
pretty close.
I was kind of surprised how
close the theory matched.
We actually on 32 processors
when you do the work spanned
calculation, you get the 65
seconds on a 32 processor
machine, here we
had 40 seconds.
But now what happens when we
scale this to the big machine?
Here we scaled it
to 512 cores.
So now we take the work divided
by the number of
processors, 512, plus 1, that's
5 seconds for this.
Here we have the work but we now
have a much larger span.
So we have two seconds of work
for processor, but now eight
seconds of span for a
total of 10 seconds.
So had we made this quote
"improvement," our code would
have been half as fast.
It would not have scaled.
And so the point is that work
and span typically will beat
running times for predicting
scalability of performance.
So you can measure a particular
thing, but what you
really want to know is this
thing this going to scale and
how is it going to scale
into the future.
So people building multicore
applications today want to
know that they coded up.
They don't want to be told in
two years that they've got to
recode it all because the
number of cores doubled.
They want to have some
future-proof notion that hey,
there's a lot of parallelism
in this program.
So work and span, work
and span, eat it,
drink it, sleep it.
Work and span, work and span,
work and span, work and span,
work and span, OK?
Work and span.